good morning beautiful morning Mark how
are you Rebecca I'm doing all right how
are you
what's going on
not much it's kind of uh a bit of a long
night just walking around I guess
you're up all night
yeah I was up all night just walking
around
dancing for a little bit and then I just
kind of went dancing for a little bit
yeah right
oh there's a
there's a bar down here it's called
pattern anyway they play pretty great
music
but in the red line for a bit and
then I was just kind of walking around
how are you I'm great
I'm great concern for you though
why because you're you seem to be
regressing you seem to be just getting
worse every
every few times I see you you're just
sliding backwards instead of
getting your life together
I'm ready to make amends no you're not
for mistakes I've made no really I am no
but I I mentioned to you before we got
on camera here that
There's an opportunity from somebody who
I'm involved with to put Rebecca into a
rehab for 12 months
it's very expensive this is a very
expensive rehab this is not a cheap one
this is not a mission
program this is a very expensive rehab
and I mentioned to you that this was
being offered
and you said you don't want to go to
Florida it's not about not going to
Florida I love Florida don't get me
wrong it's a great state I just really
want to stay out here in LA
I really want to take a shot at
Hollywood you know
I haven't really well getting yourself
clean and stable first might be great
you can that way you'll still be here
after you could get out
I know I just
shot in the dark but
I'm ready willing and able
just not
you just won't you just won't leave la
it's not like you're gonna be partying
the rehab and getting a lot of stuff
done in terms of your life and career
you're you're still going to be in a
rehab you might as well be in
Buffalo or Maine or Alaska doesn't
matter
or Florida
but I just really feel like
I don't know
I just really wanted
if you really wanted it you'd really
want it I do want it more than anything
you just don't want to go to Florida
it's sunny beautiful Florida I do love
Florida I know I had a great time in
Florida I love Florida
I just was thinking lately I don't know
this is an opportunity of a lifetime for
you I know for someone in your situation
of course I just
I know it sounds naive but I really
don't want to make it in movies
they don't really have too many studios
out in Florida no no but you're not
going to get a movie part or whatever
you're looking for in the next 12 months
living this life that you're living
you just have to accept that
there's a leeway everywhere
I'm sorry and I know I'm more than
capable
I don't know I don't believe that to be
true
you think something great is going to
happen for you in the next 12 months
living on the streets
not living on the streets maybe but
definitely if I can
sort myself out
well that's what this rehab would be
about
it would be sorting your stuff out
laughs
drugs aren't the issue
I buy that I mean I understand they're
on the surface and it looks like that's
the issue but there's probably something
deeper
how do you mean well there's probably
some something you're not dealing with
from your past or
some
chemical imbalance or something is going
on that
makes me what makes you want to run the
streets and stay up all night and do
crystal meth and
Molly and whatever else you're doing and
just
run around looking for somebody to cut
your genitals off
that's rich
with thanks I don't know
contacts I guess
I believe you're capable of probably
anything you want to do
if you're in the right frame of mind but
you're not in the right frame of mind
lately
that's not true I'm just in a tricky
sort right now
when's the last time you slept
oh a few days ago maybe like
two days ago I think
and the only reason you're not high
right now is because you're broke
no that's not true
on both counts
but I'm just kind of
I'm ready to
read re-emerge Maybe
or correct
I made it correct
certain faults
can you be more specific
I've been
I don't want to say Reckless
but
I'm ready for
the enjoyment that comes with
Mutual understanding I don't know
you're so intelligent you're so creative
you're so talented
you know and you're so self-destructive
well then
what would you consider honestly
speaking as someone who has
as they would say their [__] together
cool calm and collected
a natural progressioner you're still
very young you got to remember that it's
not like you're 45 years old you're
you're 25 25.
you go to this rehab for a year you get
your your head straight
you get you know away from all the drugs
and that this crazy lifestyle that
you're leading and then you come back to
LA and you do something great with your
life it'll make you happy
and when you're in that
uh
when you're level-headed like that oh
yeah that's not for me
rehab's not for you
I'd rather enjoy my life
than deny
that's where it comes from
you have to enjoy it
and you're enjoying this life
with certain
elements you have I know
see anyone who's is
intelligent and creative and
talented as you are well definitely if
you do something like that I have a hard
time you're gonna ever be happy unless
you're tapping into that and using it
let's go
let's
you want to take this offer
I'll consider
I'll visit you I'll come visit you five
times a year
I'd love it I just really love it here
honestly no I do too I do too
that's why I'm here Sparkle melee
Sparkle at least I'll save a spot in La
for you when you're done
you can come back
I want to do it here I don't want to do
it right yeah but if you're doing it
here you're gonna you're gonna be in a
program you're not
you know it doesn't really matter if
you're in Missouri or if you're in
Florida or L.A or
New York
you could be anywhere
and when you're out then you can decide
where you want to live
l.a'll still be here
and you'll be in a frame of mind you'll
be
perhaps better
able to more able to do whatever you
want whatever your dreams are
but right now you're not gonna you're
not going to achieve anything
when you're scrounging around for enough
money for a little bit of meth uh
well I'm ready for a complete redo then
I suspect there's probably some
chemical imbalance going on with you
that it kind of keeps you from even
wanting to get yourself straight
what do you mean
[Music]
like you're not in the frame of mind to
even accept
a great offer of
getting you know an opportunity to get
yourself
mentally better
we're all Mania
I'm sorry we're all mad here Alice yeah
yeah I know I agree but
some of us can be productive members of
society and some of us just don't want
to be
I definitely want to be and I'm ready to
contribute to society
fully
[Music]
you just don't want to give up the
street life and the drugs
I'll give them the street lives maybe
not the drugs
I could with myself off the street I'm
ready yes
drugs are an elixir in life
on his pleasure
we all think our poisonous they say
this is Hollywood baby
your father was also reaching out to
your friend
farida who
is trying to connect you guys so maybe
we can try that after this
little talk we have
your dad wants to help you out
that would be nice
I love my father
I love my father very much
he's where
I'm not sure
I really don't know where he is where
was he last
as far as you know
I don't know he's got lots of interest
in lots of places
I don't know I wouldn't want to
embarrass him on camera okay
you might not want to associate with
the scum
that I
I'm not
is that my crime
was that wanting to be a woman or is it
failing to meet the
subset standard
where am I failing
you're just being so self-destructive
that no one's going to give you an
opportunity to get a job to do anything
that you
you know you have so many talents that
might lend themselves into fashion or
or
movie industry something like that you
have a million different
areas that you could apply yourself but
no one's going to give you an
opportunity when you're so out of your
mind like this
but what my what my audience might not
understand is is these talks like this
this one right here
are the ones I these are the times where
I'll actually bring you into my studio
all the other times you're so out of
your mind that you can't even hold a
conversation
you are out of your mind most of the
time because you're so high
I think there's there's like pictures or
videos on the internet of you just on
the street like naked
acting like a total fool
I haven't seen any
I've seen some
and that and that's the reality of
Rebecca's life you let people see on my
Channel or maybe you at your best
as they say
and I can fix this all up
[Music]
I'll be better
I've seen you so many times or you tell
me these kind of things and the next day
you're out of your mind again
I give you a phone I give you clothes I
get your hotel room in the morning
you've lost all three
and you're out of your mind unable to
hold that conversation
gets really frustrating
I'm sorry
that's not it's not it's not something
to be sorry about it's just you you have
a problem and
it leads to self-destructive behaviors
can I
you gave me one more shot one more
chance I'll give you more than one more
one more
I've got an endless reservoir of
hope and forgiveness for you but that's
promising at least at the very least I
would suppose
but at some point it just becomes a
waste of my time to be buying you phones
and then you lose them three hours later
or you sell them are you selling them or
losing I'm not telling them now
you're just losing them
one was stolen one broke
um
honestly I
lose things and then I find them again
but I'm really sorry and I promise I'll
be better
foreign
is a very different day for me
today's the day oh truly Amanda
truly makes that
[Music]
not love known
I guess will you do me a favor what's
the favor will you reconsider going to
Florida for you for a year
and Mark I'd rather go to Hollywood
we have Hollywood in Florida don't they
it's not Hollywood Florida yes there is
God this is I think this place is just
up the coast from there
it's not far
definitely not far
think of going there today
that was the program and all that jobs
I'm ready to truly become
rather than
imply maybe I think you're all talk
I've heard all this stuff before
no yeah yes I have for me yeah you said
the same exact things before
and tomorrow you're going to be
so high you can't even
talk true
not true
[Applause]
all right that's something for you to
think about
I'll consider it
the offer of love
say it again the offer of love
rehabilitated I suppose
I'm just trying to help you out
thank you
yes I need all the hell up I can got
I believe in you I just don't know that
getting high
it's just so like
relentlessly like you do is is going to
lead to anything good
because when you're when you're sober
you're
you're amazing
not too true
I thought about
sobriety bones sobering thought would be
I'm
myself always high sober
drunk nothing
[Music]
unapologetically I guess I don't know
I've made mistakes
and maybe you're just not ready
I am
I am very ready
foreign
and I'm ready for it
okay we'll see
there's an offer on the table you can
you can turn away or you can maybe
accept it
I feel there's a better offer on the
horizon
I'm sorry
I want to get to work
I don't want to waste a year
rotting and some cells somewhere
I want to get to work in fact I've known
you for two three years now you haven't
made any progress you've just been
sliding backwards
that's not true it's only been about a
year and a half
sometimes you really have to get to a
point of
like an
like an original state just to
completely break it all apart just to
get back with it you know sometimes you
have to literally break your whole
[__] system part tear yourself at the
seams
just to admit
[Music]
renounce
and recount
rebuild yourself recreate yourself
reinvent yourself
Define
no I mean like if you somehow let's say
you went to Florida you went to this
rehab they got you on the medications
that might stabilize your
your brain chemistry and maybe you got
away from the crystal meth and the model
interrupted and the model
I'm sorry oh no I would never ditch the
model
you would never ditch the what
sorry I have
foreign
those that I love
people I love
love what I do and how I do
but again amends are to be made
and
honestly
today
is the right of spring
and it's the perfect day
and
From the Ashes
I guess
I'll start the practice
in reality
of all reality
to be the witch I feel
I'm destined to be here
the real me I love
I owe it
to those that I cherish
to do today's needs to be done
I'm ready to fix you
because I love you
As You Are
if you see the same for me
then you'll do right by me
I need a home and work
family and friends and Society
all I know is my behavior it really does
attract people when done right
some sick of being a mess
and I guess I'll buff and polish
start to put it together
and I apologize for the delay
sometimes I think you're just in love
with this with being this
self-destructive
enigma
old habits die hard
you're young you're 25.
because I can see very clearly that
you'll be 45 one day down here doing the
same exact
BS that will not happen
definitely not
look around
everybody else is doing it
you seen anyone else that got out
there's a very very few
have faith in me
I'm still hanging on
I'm not giving up on you
thank you very much for that
actually
I guess I'll succeed where I failed
which is um
I'm not sorry for things that had to
happen
and I'm ready
for a new chapter in this life of
Rebecca just not in Florida
maybe not now
I'm ready to take on Hollywood I think
see if I can cut the mustard I got us
yeah you take on Hollywood
not yet
but we got in there
I think
if you're not ready you're not ready
already will enable
charged
lovingly
lovingly lovingly
getting there
as they say
I think you just get off on being this
self-destructive little drama queen
adorable you're adorable though
laughs
I feel like this is my Maya please think
higher moment
there's a photo of my pizza was about
Reno
and uh
featured in General's book of the year
they're just dressed there really
quickly
beautiful oh no